je vais commencer
et partager aujourd'hui avec vous une
expérience que je
le jeu
fait à peu près un an maintenant et
j'espère vraiment que j'ai arrivée vous
intéresser que cette expérience et
pourquoi pas peut-être vous convainquent
un jour de vivre quelque chose de cette
façon donc de quoi je souhaiterais
parler de grandir et s'enrichir à
l'étranger vous arrêtez de penser
enrichir niveau financier non pas du
tout moi je me suis enrichi
professionnellement et je me suis
enrichi personnellement
alors ici vous avez une photo de moi je
dirais 3,4 en peluche panda à la main
prêt à partir découvrir le monde et je
suis pas en train de vous dire qu'à
trois quatre ans j'avais décidé que
j'allais visiter et j'avais voyagé
absolument pas c'est juste que quand on
veut on peut
il faut savoir s'en donner les moyens et
moi c'est plutôt arriver lorsque j'étais
adolescent lorsque j'étais à l'eau des
adolescents je me suis dit qu'un jour je
partirai et j'irai voyager et je pense
que ça vient de mon oncle il est parti
s'installer aux états unis lorsqu'il
avait 19 ans et je pense que c'est lui
qui m'a inspiré donc rapidement pour
présenter je m'appelle remis en selle
géant d'annecy je suis un vrai pur
petits produits aux savoyards tellement
savoyard que j'ai fait toutes mes études
annecy j'avais pas envie d'aller à lyon
j'avais pas envie d'aller à montpellier
j'étais très bien chez moi je voulais et
nulle part ailleurs et puis finalement
un jour l'opportunité s'est présentée et
j'ai essayé j'ai pris mon envol et donc
je suis parti en veilleuse j'aurais pu
faire un thème aujourd'hui sur comment
partir et sans grossir à l'étranger je
passais deux ans à l'étranger
si je vous parle de bergueira der ybbs
je sais pas si vous allez à vider le
pays où bien des sushis et de ramène les
plats ils sont super bons et le problème
c'est quand on rentre en france qu'on
regarde sur la balance qu'on a pris plus
5 à 7 kilos
c'est assez compliqué ça m'a un petit
coup au moral donc comme est expliqué
mon parcours dut licence pro et puis
après je voulais postuler au master
achats logistique à l'international à
chambéry je sais pas s'il y en a qui le
connaissent et on m'a gentiment expliqué
que c'était pas le bon parcours
bon c'est pas grave j'ai mon entreprise
en alternance j'ai recommencé j'ai
refait notre licence et puis j'ai réussi
cette licence et au moment de repostuler
pour le masters l'entreprise dans
laquelle je me trouvais m'a proposé un
vieil veilleux qui signifie how pardon
du tout
donc départ aux états unis veillez à 18
mois à cincinnati petite ville fortement
industriels dans l'ohio donc loyaux
s'épanouit york l'ohio c'est l'amérique
profonde
ça absolument pas le même genre et puis
après cincinnati je suis parti au japon
à matsumoto donc c'est une ville dans
les alpes japonaises très petites villes
et c'était super sympa pour moi c'était
la première fois que je partais en asie
et j'ai vraiment adoré j'ai passé 6 -
super c'était un vrai mais l'expérience
donc rapidement je vais parler un petit
peu roots voilà du v e dont concernant
le vih ça signifie volontariat
international en entreprise et c'est
vraiment super tremplin pour les jeunes
et je vous invite vraiment à faire des
recherches du sud parce que je pense que
ça pourrait vraiment vous intéresser
donc ça permet une mobilité
internationale de 6 à 24 mois pour des
jeunes français ou ressortissants de
l'espace économique européen pour une
entre 18 et 28 en début de mission et
donc je parle du début d'une mission
puisque vous allez partir on va vous
confier une mission un travail et donc
ce travail
vous allez recevoir des indemnités donc
rapidement quelques chiffres sur le
veilleux
c'est des chiffres qui datent de l'année
dernière ou 2018 il ya plus de quarante
mille candidats veilleux pour 10000
veilleux en poste donc il ya un étui un
veilleux sur quatre qui trouve son
bonheur
il ya plus de 2000 entreprises
utilisatrices et 130 pays concernés donc
maintenant j'ai rapidement je me suis
rapidement présentés je vais vraiment
rentré dans le coeur du sujet et donc
pourquoi je me suis pour à j'ai grandi
pourquoi je me suis enrichi à l'étranger
eh bien je me suis enrichi
professionnellement et personnellement
donc j'ai commencé dans un premier temps
avec l'enrichissement professionnel et
je vais couper ça en deux d'un côté les
états unis et d'un côté le japon donc
d'un premier cotées aux états unis
qu'est ce que ça m'a apporté
il ya vraiment une grosse différence
entre votre expérience et vos diplômes
pourquoi je dis ça parce qu'il valorise
énormément l'expérience je travaillais
dans des gestions de projets avec
quelqu'un qui a été auditeur qualité
interne
ils avaient un diplôme d'histoire et
d'archéologie et j'ai travaillé en
gestion de projet avec quelqu'un qui est
en logistique à 20 diplôme de
comptabilité et photographe il a
absolument aucun rapport
deuxième point qui m'a marqué c'est le
droit du travail aux etats-unis très
facile de charles entreprises trouver
une autre boîte ou bien très facile de
se faire virer exactement comme à la
télé vous arrivé à 8h30 il ya les rh qui
débarque et qui voit votre collègue
il lui explique qu'il y ait convoqué ça
se passe dans le bureau il revient il
récupère ses affaires on le met à la
porte
donc vraiment ça demande réflexion on se
dit waouh
j'ai un collègue qui était là il est
déjà loin faut que je trouve quelqu'un
d'autre pour avancer mon projet et
troisième point qui m'a marqué c'est la
gestion de projets aux états unis sont
très à cheval dessus gestion de projet
qu'est ce que ça coûte
qu'est ce que ça me rapporte en combien
de temps et puis productivité et c'est
assez marrant que les américains nous
parle de productivité parce que dès que
la réunion les finis tout le monde sort
en salle de pause boire un soda un café
manger un beurre pain de notre part non
et il parle de productivité en
m'expliquant qui font des semaine de 40
heures et qu'ils ont deux semaines de
congés par an alors que nous on a des
semaine de 35 heures et qu'on a cinq
semaines de congés payés problème c'est
qu'on reste quand même plus efficace que
au travail donc qu'est-ce que ça m'a
apporté les états unis adaptabilité
flexibilité au travail et gestion de
projet je connaissais la gestion de
projet mais j'ai vraiment mûri là dedans
et je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
aux etats unis se voir confier un projet
c'est vraiment très valorisant soit on
veut vous tester sans la confiance on
veut on sait que le projet va bien se
passer
depuis je rentre en france
systématiquement gestion de projet je
discute avec un collègue réponse j'ai
pas le temps est systématiquement
réponse négative du français râleurs
j'ai pas le temps trouve quelqu'un
d'autre très bien donc voila c'était
pour les états unis maintenant
différence au japon ni vos méthodes de
travail etc
les japonais très rigoureux très
rigoureux dans tout ce qu'ils font le
les plages horaires de travail sont
assez longues
ils vont pas forcément commencé à
travailler très tôt mais on finir très
tard commence à 8h 8h30 jusqu'au soir
19h30 20h 20h30 21h en fonction de la
charge de travail donc les journées sont
assez longues ils sont aussi rigoureux
par rapport à la réunion des délais il
faut vraiment respecter scrupuleusement
les délais ils sont
vachement rigoureux aussi par rapport à
la ponctualité n'arrivait jamais en
retard en réunion avec des japonais
parce qu'ils vont être très vite braquer
et puis enfin ils sont passionnés de
rangement et de nettoyage je pense que
vous avez vu par exemple la coupe du
monde aussi bien masculine que féminine
systématiquement les supporters japonais
nettoyer tribune c'est exactement pareil
là bas et toi leur maison ils nettoient
leur voiture et nettoie l'atelier
nettoie les machines et même la
direction s'y met j'arrive le matin le
directeur est là en train de passer le
balai et vraiment je me suis dit on a
vraiment beaucoup à apprendre d'eux j'ai
un bug donc vraiment une très belle très
belle très belle expérience et le japon
c'était une un contexte complètement
différent
je suis arrivé aux etats-unis j'arrive
dans une entreprise qui fonctionnait
déjà et j'avais un minimum d'anglais au
japon c'était différent mise en place de
la structure
je parle pas des japonais ils parlent
pas l'anglais et là c'était un peu
compliqué donc vraiment qu'est ce que je
retiens du japon meyer burger meilleur
rigueur meilleure attention aux détails
aux mises en forme et puis une superbe
expérience et donc dans tout ça qu'est
ce que je retiens est pourquoi je dis
que je me suis enrichi
professionnellement bas parce que je me
suis rendu compte que depuis je suis
rentré en france j'ai vraiment su garder
tout ce que j'avais appris aussi bien au
niveau des connaissances que des
compétences des fois savoir faire ou des
savoir être et j'ai vraiment j'ai
vraiment réussi à valoriser tout ça et
puis je me suis rendu compte que quelque
chose c'est qu'une fois que vous rentrez
en france
alors ça va faire maintenant un peu plus
d'un an je suis de retour à lyon j'ai un
poste de responsable qualité et je
retrouve les mêmes collègues que j'avais
quitté il ya deux ans et 102 représenter
vers eux j'ai une autorité naturelle qui
est venu puisque lorsqu'on se retrouve
sur des gestions de projets même si je
ne suis pas le pilote de gestion
le pilote du projet où je suis pas
expert dans le domaine systématiquement
va venir me poser la question pensant
que j'étais je suis une l'encyclopédique
g réponse à tout donc vraiment c'était
belle expérience et je vous invite à
vivre quelque chose comme ça
professionnellement c'est très
enrichissant
second point l'enrichissement personnel
enrichissement personnel non comme j'ai
dit les états unis cincinnati
c'est pas new york
mathis et les caricatures et les
américains mais ils aiment bien les
burgers le fast food il aime bien les
gros pick-up
il est bien les santiags et il est bien
les armes à feu et au bout de deux
semaines on est là on se dit mais
qu'est-ce que je fais là et finalement
on se rend compte que c'est simplement
qu'ils ont une culture différente et on
comprend on comprend qu'ils aient du mal
à lâcher les armes à feu parce qu'ils
ont vraiment les entreprises ont un
poids très important dans l'économie
américaine où on comprend qu'ils aillent
au fast food parce que quand on va faire
ses courses au supermarché qu'on voit le
prix des légumes et des fruits cuisine
le plat revient pas forcément moins cher
que d'aller au fast food donc il ya des
petites différences comme ça et dernier
point notable c'était que j'étais aux
états unis pour les élections donald
trump
au bout d'un mois toutes les questions
ont fusé
qu'est ce que tu penses de donald trump
images et intelligemment esquivé le
sujet parce que je me suis dit je vais
leur parler donald trump
ils sont tous pour donald trump qui vont
tous me tirer dessus donc je leur ai
gentiment fait comprendre que je venais
dans un endroit totalement différent
j'avais pas les mêmes cultures que pas
le même enseignement dont je préférerais
pas répondre sujet et puis aussi des
différences par rapport à la santé
l'université 400 $ chez le dentiste pour
faire soigner une carie ou bien commencé
son entrée dans la vie active avec un
crédit 30000 dollars il vous n'avez pas
encore commencé à travailler je vous
dire que ça mais quelques bâtons dans
les roues et puis enfin la dernière
différence celle d'un petit peu perturbé
au début c'est les américains eux mêmes
et leur comportement
je pense qu'en france c'est difficile de
se faire des connaissances et des
relations mais ensuite ça vient ces
personnes une fois qu'il ya une relation
confiance on peut compter dessus ça
vient des vrais amis et aux etats unis
pas du tout vous allez rencontrer
quelqu'un qui va vous discuté avec vous
parce que vous êtes français dans l'actu
du mcdonald's discuter avec lui 20 petit
moment et vous inviter à bord à coup
pendant trois mois vous allez voir tous
les week-ends il va déménager à chicago
et plus de nouvelles et vous dites mais
qu'est ce qu'ils me voulaient celui là
elle a disparu de ma vie aussi vite
qu'ils arrivaient et franchement
professé personnellement c'était une
belle expérience
plein de nouveaux amis partout dans le
monde
j'ai bien profité au japon de même la
rigueur
toutes les expériences que j'ai pu vivre
par exemple les japonais niveau de la
rigueur le métro à tokyo ces cinq
étoiles à côté du métro parisien
personnes se pousse ses propres tout le
monde se respecte c'est vraiment super 4
heures du matin il fait nuit
vous rentrez la rue totalement vide feu
rouge et vous traversez pas le passage
piéton si vous traversez les japonaises
vous japonais japonaise par nous ils
vous regardent ils savent que vous êtes
français parce que pour eux ça ne se
fait pas non vraiment c'était une
superbe expérience à part un petit
détail la barrière de la langue
là je vais donner une anecdote qui est
assez marrante mais sur le coup je
rigolais pas trop c'était au restaurant
yakitori c'est un restaurant qui fait
des brochettes de viande on allait
manger là bas et c'était super deux
semaines après on y retourne et le chef
nous invite à manger on lui refuse
poliment en disant qu'on préfère les
manger ailleurs il avait traduit le menu
en anglais donc la première fois qu'on y
était on comprenait pas tous des clans
j'apprenais en a commandé les numéros
deuxième fois on y va super réflexes et
grossière erreur
regardez ce qu'on a mangé deux semaines
auparavant et j'étais dans mon assiette
avec gosier de poulet anus de porc et
salades à base de sperme de poisson est
franchement je peux vous dire que je
suis contente pas comprendre le japonais
ceux ci n'ont jamais j'aurais commander
sa ouais c'est ça c'est perturbant
et pour conclure ce talk aujourd'hui
j'espère que j'ai réussi à vous
convaincre à avoue avoir motivé
si vous avez un temps dans votre tête
quelque chose qui vous dit j'ai envie de
voyager un jour je vous incite vraiment
à le faire oser tenter l'expérience
parce que vraiment c'est quelque chose
de super il ya un ami japonais qui m'a
dit voyage et ça rend sans voix et puis
ensuite se transforme en conteur
d'histoires pour la première fois qu'il
sort ça je suis dit ça y est un proverbe
japonais je comprends absolument rien et
puis non vraiment ça a du sens
une fois que vous avez voyagé vous avez
découvert une fois que vous avez
découvert vous envie de partager et moi
c'est ce que je tenais à faire
aujourd'hui partager mon expérience avec
vous j'espère que ça vous a plu
j'ai encore deux points je voudrais
aborder le vih donc levé yeux je pense
que c'est pas si donc j'ai réussi à
faire réfléchir certains d'entre eux
vous et certains ne connaissent pas je
vous invite à aller voir sur internet
c'est vraiment un outil super c'est
vraiment un véritable tremplin pour les
jeunes de la vie active
et puis le dernier point c'est qu'une
fois que vous allez partir à l'étranger
et bien vous allez vous rendre compte
que la france est un beau pays pourquoi
je dis ça parce que quand je suis parti
j'ai à mes collègues un super collègue
très bon ami jamais quitté son chez-lui
jamais quitté son pays
toujours en train de critiquer la france
puis quand je suis parti à l'étranger
unis ouais t'as raison
vas-y tu votes tu fais pas aux bâches
veut pas il a fait le est vraiment je
lui ai prouvé que finalement la france
c'est un très beau pays on a la chance
d'être français et vous allez vous-en
rencontre de deux façons quelques jours
après votre départ ou lors de votre
premier retour merci de m'avoir écouté